kim jeong-hoon also has a lot at stake
in this summit Ben Tracy shows us the
risks and opportunities for North Korea
Ben good morning to you
Jeff good morning this is by far the
furthest Kim jong-un has ever traveled
since taking over control in North Korea
in 2011 that's a sign that he feels
confident about his grip on power back
home but making a deal here in Singapore
was also a risk North Korean state media
triumphantly announced Kim Jong Un's
trip to Singapore Sunday calling it an
historic foreign tour and showing
pictures of the young leader waving as
he left Pyongyang he flew on an air
China 747 a not-so-subtle reminder of
North Korea's strongest ally and trading
partner in Singapore about a dozen
bodyguards jogged alongside his
motorcade on its way to the st. Regis
Hotel kim giman met with Singapore's
Prime Minister and yet another moment
making him look less like a pariah and
more like a politician
but is he actually willing to give up
his nuclear weapons and bring stability
to a region where North Korea has long
been a threat this is risky what Kim
jong-un is doing is without precedent
john deloria's an expert on korean
affairs at Yonsei university in seoul
the north korean system is predicated on
hostility and what kim jong-un is doing
is he's going way out of that comfort
zone and he's saying you know what we
can reconcile we can reconcile with our
ultimate enemy with the United States
many North Koreans live in poverty and
suffer from food shortages kim giman has
promised to transform his country's
economy and is looking for foreign
investment to even make it a tourist
destination all of that is nearly
impossible under strict international
sanctions which is why the North Korean
leader needs more than just a photo op
with the President of the United States
he's got to show that he's a world
statesman he's got to be able to message
that back to North Korea to say this was
a win for us
as a country as a regime Kim jong-un
would like relief from those
international sanctions but that is
unlikely going to be a result of this
summit here in Singapore the Secretary
of State says as if those sanctions will
remain in place until it's verified that
North Korea has denuclearized Jeff
Ben thanks very much we just came back
from Kim Jong Un's hotel there are
barriers surrounding the entire hotel to
prevent vehicle attacks he is staying on
the top floor in the Presidential Suite
we are going to have much more from
Singapore we'll talk more about what
we've seen and heard here over the past
day or so in our next hour but for now
let's go back to John in New York
alright Jeff thanks so much